non donc ces deux blondes hommes de
blanc sont à l'entrée devant la porte du
paradis comme ça elle attendait alors
l'autre lui
alors toi tu es morte aux commandes du
mont joli qu'aujourd'hui je suis jeune
et alors le gabon ça fait quoi de mourir
je les dis oh boh débuta très très froid
après tu deviennes bleus suit après
amazon et tu t'endors et tu sens plus
rien et tu meurs
et toi tu es morte comment dire ah là là
moi lui dis [ __ ] ça y'a je croyais que
mon mari me tromper j'étais sûr et
certain que mon mari me tromper alors
les jours je suis parti du bureau je
suis arrivé l'après-midi à la maison
lachaîne entré dans la maison et j'ai
ouvert la porte comme ça j'ai vu mon
mari regarder la télé géorgie c'est pas
possible ils me cassent quelque chose
alors là j'ai vite couru dans la chambre
à coucher j'ai regardé y avait personne
j'aime vite couru dans la cuisine j'ai
regardé avait personne
j'ai dit au regard de notre charmant
évite de courir et personne chez moi au
premier étage un courant il y avait
personne
là je suis monté au grenier avait
personne je t'ai soufré largement d'une
crise cardiaque et l'autre lui dis oh
[ __ ] tu aurais ouvert le congélateur
n'ont été sauvés tous les deux
alors elle est assez vite vas-y bonne
série à lévis il fait celles qui
arrivent chez son gynéco et donc mal
s'installe comme ça et puis il commença
le sculpter comme ça et elle entend dire
kesha tennant google vient savin docteur
ça fait trois fois quand même pourquoi
vous le répéter quand même je suis gêné
il dégage sa tête il fait mais c'est pas
moi c'est l'écho tu entends dessus non
je de cet art est mort car tu peux en
faire deux tribus arabes qui c'est un
arabe qui achètent une maison voisine à
celle d'un médecin dans un lotissement
où toutes les maisons se ressemblent et
donc qu'ils croisent le médecin le
lendemain matin et il va voir le médecin
et dit franchement très très belle
maison on a une très belle maison
il est dommage que la mienne et coûte
deux fois plus cher que la vôtre le
message dit mais comment c'est possible
elle peut pas coûté deux fois plus cher
que la mienne on a les mêmes maisons
elles sont identiques on est dans un
lotissement c'est exactement la même
maison et dit oui mais moi j'habite à
côté d'un médecin et vous à côté d'un
arabe
parce qu'il arrive en retard oui alors
ça n'a racheté que sur ça c'est un homme
qui va boire un café en terrasse
et le serveur vient lui apporter son
café avec un petit sucre comme ça et la
ram il dit excusez moi et écoute combien
la caf et là ça m'a dit coûte 2 euros et
10 le sucre et coûte combien
edit le sucre c'est gratuit edit ah mais
moi un kilo de sucre soppe-le-bas du
bourget c'est vrai ah oui tu vas pas de
moquer mais on arrête on est très
content tu sois là c'est un curé de
paroisse qui en a ras le fion de
commencer dès samedi et dimanche
je veux que ma vie à 100 à son
assistante tu va me remplacer pendant
huit jours voie générale puis on prend
un peu d'air parce que lens ont tous à
100 mais je voulais même samedi pour la
confesse moi je ne sais pas ce qu'il
faut faire
je te laisse une liste occupe pas sur
l'est une liste taquin suivent depuis
ses tout vert à hulshout show amuse toi
bien s'en va le sundae arrive première
confession
mon père pardonne et moi car j'ai péché
oui je vous écoute ma fille
ben voila j'ai pêché par gourmandise
avait fait une tarte aux prunes pour les
enfants puis je pense y ont assisté
s'est posé en entier bon alors
gourmandie lourds man 10 3 pater et 2 av
suivante
alors moi je joue un raccourci dans mon
village j'ai fait un déchet très grave
je fais comment dire je fus une pie par
un à l'ami de mon mari bon du phi phi
phi phi phi phi maire de lons et un
enfant de choeur qui passe m6
qu'est ce qu'il donne pour une pipe
monsieur le curé un bounty
[Applaudissements]